i know some of you went fairly rapidly
to a solution which is great if you've
encountered something like this
before but actually i'm far less
interested in like this is a category of
problems that you will start to see a
fair bit of and you're like oh
great actually it's the thinking that
i'm really interested in and the use of
geometric reasoning which
is not the point of like the answer but
is the point of the question
let me say that again the geometry
reason is the point
of the question because we want you to
think about what is this
shape here i think most of you pretty
rapidly worked out
it is a modulus that's consistent around
a particular point in other words
a circle what is that particular point
by the way
root 2 plus root 2i because you could
have written this as and i hope some of
you did
uh minus root 2 plus root 2i so that
clarifies what the reference point is uh
these locus questions often have one or
two reference points that matter
and then you fix them in place and
everything sort of orbits around them
quite literally sometimes the actual
answer you produce is just going to be
a range for mod z it's just going to be
a range
for args here we are not asking you to
construct a long
15 page proof for every reason here but
if you do not have that reasoning clear
in your head
and i saw it as i walked around and had
a look some of you are like how did you
even get that answer like the numbers
are fine but
but why okay so here's what we're going
to do
if we're content that this circle is the
locus you get from this
equation let's take these one at a time
the modulus is significantly easier
than the argument but the arguments are
too hard if you know what direction to
look in we want to find the greatest and
least values of
mod z what does that mean
z can be anywhere on the circumference
of this circle it can float around and
anywhere on this circumference
will satisfy this point because they're
all one unit away
from our reference point here okay but
obviously
some of these z's are further from the
origin
than others so to look for the greatest
and least value means
i want the z that's the furthest away
from the origin
and i want the z that's the closest
that's all that means okay so we can see
through the notation
to understand what's being asked of us
at this point i hope several of you drew
array from the origin and slicing right
through see if i can aim there we go
right through the center of the circle
because this shows to you and i hope
your diagram is good enough if it's not
good enough not big enough to see what's
going on here then
maybe re consider drawing your diagram
or drawing a bigger one next time
you've got these two spots here one and
two which are respectively the uh
closest and furthest points z can be
from the origin does that make sense so
really then all that follows is
find the modulus of this find the
modulus of that that's your particular
range how do i
do that how do i find the modulus of
these points go ahead again
so we know that the center is root
so we find the length from the origin to
the center
so you're looking for this distance here
yes yes
fantastic so just carry on you said uh
route 2
plus route 2i so help us out guys like
anger's given you
on a silver plate what's the piece of
knowledge we used to get to that length
that's just pythagoras right so we know
that distance is
two it's two and then where do we go
from there
just add one to get the maximum that's
the bonus and we subtract one yeah
perfect okay so we know we know what
this distance is
right and we know what our two least and
greatest points are for the modulus
based on
their distance from the center they
should be one from the center so you
just
add and subtract so being that this is a
two
that means if you go backwards one unit
this spot must be how far
from the origin that's one isn't it so
you could put that right there that's
one
and then if you went the whole distance
it'll be two plus one
so that's three so i guess the way we
would say that is the range
for mod z is between one and three
you okay with that that's the least and
greatest values fantastic
now i did say that was the easy part now
we need to do the slightly trickier bit
uh and this is where
this property is going to come into play
right
i had some of you i was watching and
having a look at the constructions you
were making
i had some of you say well i'm trying to
do the same thing i'm trying to find z
can move around
right and depending on where it moves
you will get different values for the
argument
right if you go here it's like we'll
have your angle of rotation up here
if you go over there you have your angle
rotation so on so arg z can
vary and then you realize well i want
the part that gives me the smallest
angle and the biggest angle
now several of you selected this spot
right
here it's uh vertically beneath
the uh center of the circle right which
is not a bad guess
like that certainly gives you a smaller
angle than like one of these spots right
but it doesn't give you the smallest
angle it doesn't give you the smallest
argument what is the spot that i need to
choose
yeah so the tangent of the circle that
passes through the origin
the the tangent to the circle
that passes through the origin
yeah okay now this is interesting right
because what you just described to me
and i want you to think about this right
the tangent to this circle that passes
through the origin
that seems ambiguous to me because i can
think of for any point
anywhere outside the circle i can think
of two tangents that will go through
that point
and we'll make the circle right can you
think and maybe on your diagram
you've got these already right there's a
tangent that's going to actually go up
this way
and that's going to give you the
greatest auxide and then you got to the
one that
joe was trying to get at first this
lower one which will give us the
lowest okay so in fact and you really
need to do this accurately
so much so that i'm actually going to
pull out the rule for this right you
need to do this
carefully because if you actually have
something that is a decent circle
even on the strength of your diagram you
should see it's close
but it's not exactly at that that bottom
most part of the circle do you see that
right
in fact as i draw it now let me see if i
knew this accurately enough
do you see that what's my argument
uh sorry what's my logic answer my logic
is the diagram right you can even see
right there it's only i can only do this
because my diagram is like
halfway decent to be able to use that as
a point now
that's where this circle property which
i told you you'd need to sort of rest on
is going to help you out that tangent is
perpendicular to the radius
at point of contact what does that let
you do when you know you've got a right
angle here
what does that enable i have a thing
over here
pythagoras theorem again but this time
in well
i mean you actually don't need
pythagoras's theorem you can use it but
i've already got this distance here
right it's the radius okay
um because angus helped us do this by
for the mod z i've already got the
opposite
and the hypotenuse for the actual
angle over here which is going to help
us be our sort of step to
getting what auxed is for this point
does that make sense
this is not an accidentally chosen
triangle by the way what is
that theta down there it's going to be
pi on
6 part 6 right because this is the 1 2
root 3 triangle this is just sine
theta equals a half right so i'm going
to put in i'll get this out of the way
that's equal to pi on six
right now this angle here theta it's
actually not the one i want
what is the where is i should say not
what where is
the arg z that i'm after to give me the
lowest
yeah it's value underneath that pi on
six right so in fact and you need to
have this clearly marked in your diagram
this is the actual angle that i want how
do i find it
go ahead kevin what is it
pause pirate four pirate four kevin just
said pilot before which we need
where did it come from where is pi over
four here
because we know that from the center
it's actually
true
yeah fantastic so this triangle here
which
um anger used to help us get this two
right it's a it's an isosceles triangle
so you've got pi on 2 here
pi on 4 in the corners so coming back to
calvin now
there's the pi divided by 4 and he is
subtracting the pi
over 6. is that okay so that gives you a
lower bound i hope pi over
pi over 4 subtract pi over six that
gives you pi over
12 right so that is our lower boundary
for args there now i'm going to pause
here right at this point
hopefully you realize why i had to say
the principal argument i'm now asking
for a maximum value right
if you don't restrict yourself to the
principal argument
you can just make it anything you like
you're like i want my angle to be bigger
i'll just rotate a few more times around
right
so i'm clearly only looking for the
principal argument to
this other tangent that i'm going to
have up to
here that was not bad by hand that i'm
not going to be able to do that next
time
how do you find this one how do you find
this one
you guys are good answer for this one
calvin can someone else help us reason
to get to
up there
yeah in fact does this ring a bell do
you remember how we went from here
and we added subtracted do you remember
that right it's exactly the same logic
to go from here and then we add
or subtract the relevant size of the
angle this time
it's pi on 4 and we add pi on 6 to get
to the next one
pi on 4 plus pi on 6 that's five pound
twelve
do i remember it right happy times
okay so this is not really like a
separate category of question
this is do you understand how the graph
works and then can you think of like
like your trigonometry and pythagoras
from stage four
stage five stuff you learned a long time
ago but maybe just this
a little dusty in your head